innovation comes from
questioning the way things have been
done before yeah um and if in the
education system
you're taught not to do that that will
inhibit uh
entrepreneurship i'd invest as much in
myself as you can i mean you're your own
biggest asset by far i would definitely
advise
a small disturb company to be as narrow
and as focused as is possible to be
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside youtube
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
best lessons from warren buffett elon
musk and other billionaire entrepreneurs
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one question things with elon
musk innovation comes from
questioning the way things have been
done before yeah um and if in the
education system
you're taught not to do that that will
inhibit uh
entrepreneurship being able to question
what you're being taught being able to
yeah
i mean just you know saying well is
there a better way yeah um you know to
ask that question lesson number two use
your potential with warren buffett the
habits you develop and and i go back the
other thing is have the right heroes i
mean i've always been lucky in that
respect and
if you know if you the people you look
up to
are going to form your vision of what
the world you know how you want to be in
later life
and the one
well i'll give you two pieces of advice
i'd invest as much in myself as you can
i mean you're your own biggest asset by
far i mean you've got you've got all
kinds of potential all the people in
this room you know you're lucky to be in
this country gotten a good education
but
most people go through life using up a
very very small part of their potential
and so anything you do that invests in
yourself
uh
is that's the best investment you can
possibly make and then i would i would
follow my passion i mean whatever turned
you on
you know i uh
i found i was lucky i found something
early that that turned me on but but uh
you don't want to take a job just for
the money you don't want to take a job
for an organization that you really
don't feel good about or work for people
that you don't feel good about you you
really want to be excited when you get
out of bed every morning and it won't
necessarily be the job that you have 10
years later
but you'll be learning so much as you go
along and you know i i took a job with
ben graham my hero and and
you know i never asked the salary and i
found at the end of the month when i got
my first paycheck what i was earning
because i just knew it was the right
thing to be
to be doing so i would i would i would
follow
follow your passion lesson number three
start with a narrow focus with jeff
bezos i would definitely advise
a small stirrup company to be as narrow
and as focused as is possible to be if
you look at the original amazon business
plan
there was no hint of anything other than
books in it and it was not on my radar i
was thinking i wanted to build an online
bookstore that was it
and um you know worked way better than i
thought it would and we launched music
and that worked better than i thought it
would and we launched videos i think
it's so long ago i can really remember i
think it was actually vhs tapes is that
possible
and um and that worked better than we
thought it would and then i sent email
to customers so i picked about a
thousand customers and i said
besides the things we sell today books
music and video what would you like to
see us sell and the list came back
incredibly long tails almost like
whatever was on their mind at the moment
it was like i wish you sold windshield
wipers for my car and i was like really
windshield wipers that wasn't done the
business plan but that's an interesting
idea and so
um today we basically if you're buying
your windshield wipers anywhere else
you're probably getting ripped off um
and um
so um so it's been uh you know kind of
one foot in front of the other lesson
number four get new problems with grant
cardone if you're having problems right
now
okay like like if you're having
recurring problems
just make a list
make a list of
make sure you guys do what grant says
remember he's a t-rex
yeah yeah make a list
make a list of your recurring problems
that you're sick of
the same stuff over and over again man i
don't have enough time i don't have
enough money
uh
i i don't get to take whatever the
recurring problems are i can't good good
people uh uh i i got a i got one person
in my office that i depend on and i'm
sick and dependent on him even though
he's a producer
those recurring problems that you have
over and over again
uh you lose deals you lose you don't you
don't like your clients you actually
have clients that that you'd like to get
rid of you know how you get rid of bad
clients get more of them
okay so what i do is if i have problems
let's say i'm making a million dollars a
year i'm making one million
and i'm like okay next year this is what
this is what business owners do
they're like i'm this year i'm going to
go from 1 million to 1.2 million i'm
going to get a little growth and then
covid cracks you
and then you're like okay i'll settle
for 500 grand now
the problem was you were looking for
incremental growth okay you know the old
thing about three steps forward two
steps backward you only get one step out
of that by the time by the time a week
or two goes you're like i'm sick of this
i'm tired i'm bored
i'm beat up and your life doesn't change
the trick is
that if you would plan out how to get to
10 million even though you're not let me
just go ahead and asterisk that right
now
don't have a plan to go from one
to one point two
build a plan to go from one to ten
million because it's going to give you a
new set of problems
okay and a takeaway for you today get
new problems
because if you keep
working on the set of problems that you
have you will never solve them
okay watch uh i got a handful of
problems i'm making a million dollars a
year or 200 grand or whatever your
number is pick your number
and i'm like i'm gonna get me
incremental growth how do i do that with
the people i have the time i have the
office i have
well what you do is you're like i'm
gonna go from 1 million to 10 million oh
i need a new office new problem
oh i need 10 people not two people
oh i need to spend
a hundred grand a month on advertising
not five thousand see got all of a
sudden i got new problems
i'm no longer thinking about pete the
the the the uh
uh what do they call the guy that you're
so the diva the diva jessica i gotta put
up with jessica's [ __ ] because she's
a diva comes in when she wants leads
when she wants
uh she runs the business even though i
own it she tells me what to do she's
really the boss even though i write the
checks
okay so i'm like i'm gonna go get 20
jessica's
you follow what i'm saying i'm going to
build
like a lot of you are worried about debt
i remember in 2008 i owed 50 million
dollars to the bank
and i'm like i told my wife this will
never happen to me again the bank was
pushing me around like bullying me
around like a punk
and and i said elena this will never
ever happen to us again and she's like
what are you gonna do to prevent it i
said the next time this country goes
upside down i'm gonna owe a billion
dollars in debt hey man how you doing
buddy good how are you you got a book
coming out don't you
uh you just came out
where can people get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael he's got a new
book out build a serve go grab it today
at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five pay attention and learn with
oprah winfrey i'm going to continue
developing shows that speak
to
the humanity of people in a way that
makes them want to
live better and do better
and
that exalts their their their victories
and lets them know that they are
important and meaningful in the world
you know i would have to say
that
every day david that show was such a it
was like therapy for me kind of like now
every day this show
was
i paid attention so i've never been to a
therapist but uh i i i paid attention
all those days on the show and i made
therapy acceptable for a lot of people
who thought uh not me not so
one of the things i started to get
uh
around
mid to late no no mid to late 90s is
that everybody that i had on the show at
the end of the show would say something
to me like
um
was that okay was that okay how was that
was that okay right at the end of the
interview
and i started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was um i i had gone and
done a show where i was in um
a prison i was interviewing a father
who
was in jail for life for murdering his
twin daughters and at the end of the
interview even behind bars he said to me
is that okay
how'd i do
and barack obama said it when he sat in
the chair the first time and george bush
said it beyonce said it at the end of
she taught me how to talk and then said
is that okay
so that's an acquired skill do they yes
working thing but this is what i learned
uh sitting in that chair for 25 years
that at the end of the day whether you
are
interviewing me or i get to interview
you
whatever your profession is
wherever you are in your life in your
relationships
every person that you encounter every
experience the person wants to know
was that okay
was that okay
and what i started to hear was that what
people are really saying is did you hear
me
did you hear me
and did what i say mean anything to you
and so i started to listen
with that in mind with that intention of
validating that your being here
you're speaking to me you're taking the
time to do this with me is important
because you matter and that's true for
everybody who's watching or listening
that every argument that you ever have
every encounter the person just wants to
know did you hear me did you see me and
did i say anything
lesson number six measure the good and
bad impact with bill gates we should
always measure um
the good impacts and the bad impacts of
the stuff we have
you know certainly
whenever a new technology comes along
there's a lot of fear about what's going
to do
you know when the printing press came
along
there was a great fear that people would
just read books and not go out and seek
you know real experiences and and you
know i tried that when i was a kid just
reading books and you know maybe i'd be
more rounded if there hadn't been books
around so i you know i think it's hard i
don't i haven't seen any evidence of any
significance that socialization
has really broken down in some bad way
you know i know that
you know with skype now
i meet my daughter's
boyfriend's parents uh when i walk into
her bedroom uh and there they are on on
skype so socialization is changing
but i don't think
i'm not sure you can really say that
there's a a negative vector there and
there's so many positive vectors about
if you're curious and you want to learn
something you know i was young and i'd
ask a question about hey what's
fertilizer
you know if the world book didn't have
it i wasn't going to get the answer now
of course you can go online watch videos
and and
you know my children are always asking
questions where if i don't know the
answer we just go and it's actually kind
of fun to learn it together so i'd say
on balance
uh you know i think we're quite quite
far ahead
you know there are some things about
privacy you know maybe misuse of overuse
of pornography
you know letting your kids play too many
video games so you have to set a quota
just like
i had to have a quota for how much i was
allowed to read
but uh
and i think overwhelmingly
we've got mostly positive things
including the opportunity ahead of us of
how the tool gets used in mainstream
education and lesson number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is find your gift with mark cuban
my dad busted his ass i mean he worked
six six days a week um lit left at seven
at seven seven thirty in the morning got
back at six or seven o'clock
lost his eye in an accident doing
upholstery he had a staple break when he
was putting um
some
covering on a car seat
you know it was it was a middle class
uprinking my mom did odd jobs you know
they they just wanted something better i
mean my grandparents came over from
russia and you know my dad was the first
generation my uncles were the first
generation americans like my mom too and
you know like every child of immigrants
they wanted better for their kids you
know it's funny i mean a lot of people
grow up that way right but not many
people end up like you so what do you
think that's the result of
i think
you know
everybody's got something that they're
good at and the hard part is just
finding it and i found out early that i
was a good salesperson that i really
liked business you know like i like
sports i mean i read everything i
possibly could played sports as much as
i could just wasn't as good as i wanted
to be and and business was the same way
i mean as long as i could remember i was
buying and selling baseball cards
garbage bags
whatever i could find stamps um to
collectors
but i was also reading everything i
possibly could about business and you
know i was that unusual kid that i'd
rather read about ted turner than go to
the movies and and so i think that
created a foundation of my parents you
know my dad used to always say i don't
understand what you're doing
but i'm glad you're doing it and and so
i have my ups and downs along the way of
course but um i just think that i just i
just put in the time and was fortunate
enough to really get excited about
business and that paid off benefits over
the long haul now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week the science
says that when you just watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following through on
your goals 35 that's not enough that's
not enough just to get motivated believe
nation we're here you're here today
matters you're an action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video
and your plan of action specific for the
next week put it down in the comments
below and i'm going to show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
everyone thinks that spanx actually
started when i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose but the truth is it started
many many years before that it started
when i was selling fax machines
door-to-door
getting kicked out of office buildings
day in and day out and i woke up one
morning and i thought
i'm in the wrong movie
how did this happen this is not my life
cut scene call the director call the
producer no and i took out a piece of
paper and i wrote down what i was good
at
and there was not much on the page the
word i saw the word sales i knew i was
good in sales so i wrote down in my
journal
i want to invent a product that i can
sell to millions of people
that will make them feel good
and then i asked the universe for an
idea
and i waited for two years
and the idea showed up
and the minute i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose i decided to pursue it
so
what do you do when you have an idea and
you've never taken a business class or
worked in fashion or retail
i wanted to patent my idea
and i ended up
looking for a female patent attorney and
i called the georgia chamber of commerce
and they said there actually wasn't a
single female patent attorney in the
entire state of georgia
so i looked in the yellow pages and
found three men's name and went out and
pitched my idea to them and they
actually thought the idea was so bad
that one of the patent lawyers later
admitted to me he thought i'd been sent
by candid camera
which makes sense because he was looking
around the room for the hidden cameras
but he ended up eventually helping me i
went to barnes noble bought a book on
patents and trademarks wrote my own
patent
and went back to him and said please
please will you just write the claims
portion of it and he did for a
discounted price
but it makes me think about inventors
and innovators and when you hear those
words do you think of women
last year my son
had inventor week at his school and they
asked me to come and be the keynote
speaker at his kindergarten class
so
i was the uh inventor that was coming
and i started out looking at all these
cute little kids and i said so what does
an inventor look like
and all their hands shot up and one kid
said it's a man and he has crazy hair
and somebody else raised their hand and
said no no it's a bald man no it's a
tall man it's a short man
and i just stopped and i said
well i'm an inventor
and their eyes got really big and they
said you are
and it dawned on me i looked around the
room and all the pictures of inventors
were albert einstein thomas edison steve
jobs so i can see why the the young girl
who asked me and said i didn't know
girls could be inventors was surprised
and even my son on the way home he goes
mom you're an inventor
but the real point of all of this was i
wanted to help women and i'm so
passionate about it and it's amazing
that i started with their butts
and i've continued to groan i started at
the sarah blakely foundation because i
truly believe that the world would be a
much better place if the male and female
energy on the planet was more balanced
how would you describe each phase of the
evolution of oracle and how would you uh
sort of describe running each of those
phases you got to do this quick
i gotta well i mean and clearly being a
part of a company with four people and
being a part of a company and by the way
we're 85 000 now post post merger with
sun you know uh uh 100 uh we think about
sun's got about 20 000 employees and you
know uh 25 000 employees we're about 105
000.
uh so uh hundred five hundred ten
thousand we're not sure exactly about
that uh i mean clearly my job is
constantly changed uh what has not
changed is i ran engineering
at oracle on the first day
i run engineering today the one part of
the company i have always paid attention
to and i is always reported directly to
me is engineering not sales not
marketing not support and not consulting
not services at various points in time
lots of other people have run run those
operations the back office
accountings order management all of
these things the only thing that i've
done consistently during those 32 years
is run engineering because i believe
basically that once you reach
you will you know you'll win as as we
said oracle it's amazing our good
products seem to do very well and our
bad products
not so well
so the thing i focused on and i think we
get the most most leverage is developing
the right products recruiting the right
engineers and having the right
organization so mr buffett in the past
you invested in china south korea and
israel um and recently you partnered
with 3g capital and joshua lemon
from brazil over for the heinz deal
does this mean are you tempted to
venture into the brazil market next
i didn't get the question question you
did the heinz deal the question is are
you going to invest in brazil next oh uh
i don't know where i'm going to invest
next that's what that's what makes my
job interesting i mean
i'm i'm not kidding i mean if you went
out and played golf
and every drive went in the hole you'd
give up the game wouldn't be interesting
i mean
what's interesting is when you get in
the rough and you have to come out and a
few things like that so i
i love the fact that i don't know what
i'm going to do next you mentioned the
israel investment
in 2006 in the fall
i got a letter from a fellow
and i never heard of him
and i never heard of the company he was
talking about but he said my name is
eton wardheimer
and i want to tell you a little about my
company ishkar the letter was a page and
a half long and he said
if he sold the company the family sold
the company the only company they wanted
to sell it to was berkshire hathaway and
if i was interested they'd be glad to
come over from israel and explain it to
me and it was a it just jumped off the
page that this was an interesting idea
so i emailed them and they came over
very shortly and
and we bought the business we we handed
them
four billion dollars for 80 of a company
where i'd never seen it or anything etan
kept saying you got to come over to
israel and see the plants and everything
you won't believe how wonderful they are
and i said hey tom
i don't go to council bluffs iowa you
know i mean
i am doing fine in omaha and
uh he said no you know you got to see it
i said no no i don't i i said we can
make a deal without seeing it he said
well if you buy if you buy the company
will you come and see it i said if we
buy the company i'll come so we bought
the company and i went over there and
it's true i've never seen plants like
this it was the greatest operation i've
ever seen and etan said to me said you
know
that's why i want you to come over to
see these things i said listen if i'd
come and see them i'd have paid more
money so
so it
uh
we
we have a wonderful partnership with the
people in israel but i don't know
tomorrow
uh our partnership with the people in
brazil with george apollo lemon and his
associates they are sensational people
uh i got to know george apollo when i
was on the port of gillette with him and
the opportunity to buy into a wonderful
business like heinz
and to be partners and they do
they'll do all the heavy lifting they
run the place uh with georgie powell and
associates i mean it it's just
it's a it's a great opportunity for us
and i don't know what the opportunity
will be tomorrow with george apollo is
last december
uh
i was going out to boulder colorado
where he had a group that met and he
said i think i've got an idea might
interest you when i get out there and so
i went out there and and uh and as we
came back on the plane he explained what
he was thinking about in terms of heinz
and i said
count me in and
uh and i will tell you one other thing
which is quite impressive about him
after i said that and went a little a
little further on the thing he sent me a
one-page
governance description of how it would
work between the two of us and he sent
me a very brief description of
what he thought would be a fair deal for
both of us i didn't have to change a
word during my california springs and
summers i spent most of my days in the
high sierras in yosemite valley working
as a river guide
and a rock climbing instructor
i loved those jobs
but unfortunately they didn't pay that
well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley
i learned a program in college
i didn't love programming
but it was fun
and i was good at it
and computer pro programming gave me the
same kind of satisfaction as solving
math problems and playing chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life
i thought i was making real progress on
my journey of self-discovery
i had found a cause
i had a couple of jobs that i loved
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife
was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing foolish things
she wanted me to work full time as a
computer programmer or go back to
college and finish my degree
we compromised
sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember was a sailing class
taught at berkeley marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said
this was the single stupidest idea she
had ever heard in her entire life
accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out
and then she divorced me
[Music]
this was a pivotal moment in my life
[Applause]
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time
i was not disappointed in myself
for failing to be
the person they thought i should be
their dreams
and my dreams were different
i would never confuse the two of them
again i know you all understand better
than most that real progress requires
authentic
an authentic way of being
honesty and above all empathy
i have to say
that the single most important lesson i
learned in 25 years talking every single
day to people
was that there is a common denominator
in our human experience
most of us
i tell you we don't want to be
divided what we want the common
denominator that i found in every single
interview is we want to be validated
we want to be understood
i've done over
35 000 interviews in my career
and
as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to me and
inevitably in their own way asks this
question
was that okay
i heard it from president bush
i heard it from president obama
i've heard it from heroes and from
housewives i've heard it from victims
and perpetrators of crimes i even heard
it from beyonce and all of her beyonce
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says was that okay
friends and family yours enemies
strangers in every argument in every
encounter every exchange i will tell you
they all want to know one thing
was that okay
did you hear me
do you see me
did what i say mean anything to you
and even though this is the college
where facebook was born
my hope is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people you may disagree with
[Music]
that you'll have
the the courage
to look them in the eye and hear their
point of view
and
help make sure that the speed and
distance
and anonymity of our world doesn't cause
us to lose our ability to stand in
somebody else's shoes and recognize all
that we share as a people this is
imperative for you as an individual and
for our success as a nation if i sit
with a hundred dollars in my pocket
folks there is no
economy if you want to be economic you
let money flow it has to move you got
people in your company managers and
executives that are saving money they
save their money i'm like what are you
doing dude we're saving money how can
you grow a department if you go home and
all you do is save it
you know you open up somebody's freezer
and they got ice cream that's three
months old it's got this much left in
you you got you got diet coke that's
four days old it's got that much left in
it okay you got ziploc containers you
have whole cabinets of ziploc containers
and little plastic things where you in
case you had some leftover corn or peas
or potatoes you're like don't throw it
away
save that
save that that much pork chop maybe i'll
hit it tomorrow
see somebody put this back in here
that's probably elena doing that there's
no reason to put this back here it
reminds me of my mama
reminds me of when i grew up save
everything
it's a terrible product anyway why you
want to save it look at this she put two
apples in here don't put them back in
the refrigerator man
eat them or toss them
you're not going to go broke
or get rich
saving leftovers
what are you guys doing man you got it
in your closet that you ain't ever gonna
wear it don't fit you it ain't fit you
in in years
right how many of you got stuff at your
house you could get rid of
you're trying to save stuff
dude how can you how can you have new
stuff come in when you're holding on to
stuff that you don't even use
right so you have to use this it only
becomes valuable when it's used
now the question is what are you going
to use it on and the other question is
why don't you use it
why are you so compelled to hold on to
it
what do y'all think that is
you don't know how to get more number
one reason i don't your mother did not
know how to get a new shirt
that's why she took so much put so much
time and energy in cleaning the shirt
you got a stain on
okay you broke a toy your parents got
upset with you can't believe you did
that
what did what man dude
toys are to be broken
that's what a good toy is for
right
right i lost a quarter when i was eight
years old and i would have thought i
would have thought my house
was gonna get torn apart because my dad
became so upset about the quarter you're
playing with money never play with money
what are you doing playing with money
and that that that lesson pounded on me
so hard it kept me from making real
money for 20 years you know people often
ask me um what it takes to start a
business what is the key ingredient how
do i how do i start the business and how
do we grow to about 20 million dollar 20
million dollars in sales so quickly
you know they all come up with some new
whiz-bang idea they're going to invent
the the better mouse trap they're going
to come up with new software new
hardware and more often than not it
seems like they've spent their millions
before they they thought through their
idea
but when we talk about new companies and
and growth and success there really is
only one common ingredient across any
type of business whether it's oil or
computers or software anything and that
key ingredient is customers
without customers whether you're
starting a business running a business
expanding a business you don't have a
business
there is no business customers are the
key ingredient get those profits
you gotta have the customers
you gotta have happy customers
that's the bottom line
you know micro solutions we've been
we've been going and growing and it's
impossible not to have growing pains
it's impossible not to make mistakes we
screw up all the time
and you know it doesn't bother me as
president if i ever if i have an
employee who just didn't do something
right just made a mistake
it's good
because if you're not making mistakes
you're not trying hard enough you know
these things i'm saying they're not
unique they're not things that i just
thought up in some some miracle growth
you know things when i talk to people in
our company when i talk to people about
our company i never have a unique
thought i can't remember i don't know
that i ever did i can't remember if i
ever will or don't expect ever to
there's no magic formulas to customer
service there's no magic formulas to
doing things right these these sayings
that you hear me say are things that
i've read elsewhere and just regurgitate
back
but how many people do them
you know we all know the golden rule
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you
and that's nice you know but do you do
it
but even more importantly than the
golden rule what about the lover's rule
do unto others as you would love to have
them do unto you
that's what we try to stress the micro
solution that's what we try to use to
differentiate ourselves
not just to get by because everybody's
going to be nice
you know when you invite someone into
your house that is an acquaintance that
you like okay you're going to offer them
coffee
you're going to offer them a donut and
that's really what you expect you know
if you went to their house because
you're just acquaintances but when you
leave the house
it was nice
if you go that's fine if you don't go
back fine that's the way customers look
at businesses
if i go back fine if i don't go back
fine
you know they say that eighty percent of
the people who have a problem tell at
least ten people
only ten percent of the people who had a
good experience tell anybody
and it's the same way when you go to
visit an acquaintance
and when people come to try to do
business with micro solutions i hope i
pray and i try to convey to each and
every one of our people
that we give them a reason
to want to come back
we give them the reason to do a good
morning rap to say okay let's do
business with micro solutions
you've got to really concentrate to do
unto others as you would love to have
them do unto you even after you had done
your thing there was still an eighth
course to make sure that yahoo itself
was on track do you know what that was
about yeah they were screwing everything
up you know i mean look they had they
had an opportunity to dominate um
streaming media they also owned at the
same time the patent to cost per click
yeah right now google's entire business
to this day
is built around
pay-per-click rather they're not calling
pay-per-click yeah
so they had the entire patent for
pay-per-click
had they just said sorry google you
can't use it
there would be no google
instead they said yeah 133 million
dollars and give us some stock
they were just too nice
right which blinded them in a lot of
respects and i remember walking in with
a 32 million dollar sale
saying okay we're gonna do streaming
we're gonna sell all this company's
content you know it's worth 32 million
dollars for us and it's going to pre-up
these other potential competitors and um
i forget it was jerry or tim whoever
said no
we don't work that way we don't preempt
competition we just leave it open
i'm like okay it's time for me to go buy
a basketball team
that's they just they just didn't see
these things and i mean it's a lesson in
your businesses there's going to be
everybody's always trying to kick your
ass
and you have to figure out how to kick
your out your own ass first
seriously because if you're not brutally
honest with yourself and your own
business about what your frailties are
someone else is going to find them yahoo
didn't get that yahoo just thought you
know what we're just going to continue
moving forward and we'll just compete
with everybody else and you know there's
we have no other problems one time you
know as you know i went to indiana
and
in dallas in the mid 90s you know when
when we had a good basketball team
we literally would when we wanted to
listen to our big games like indiana
purdue go hoosiers um we would call
somebody in bloomington who would put a
radio next to a speaker phone and dial
us and we'd sit on the other side
listening over a speakerphone drinking
our beer and whipping it up or doing
whatever and the internet was just
starting to happen and now i'm a tech
geek and i'm like into all of it and
we're like
there's got to be a better way to do
this and so one of my buddies from
indiana todd wagner was like look we've
been thinking about this and i'm like no
i'll figure it out i'm a networking guy
now and so we
looked for ways to
um
stream indiana basketball we called it
net casting back then over the brand new
internet and so i went out and bought a
packard bell 90 megahertz computer and
an isdn line
and downloaded all the software and i
said you know what i'm going to figure
it out
and lo and behold by
oh golly early 1995 we had figured out a
way
um
we would we took these eight-hour vcrs
and connected it to a local radio
station record them we'd bring them back
go through this process called encoding
and put it up on this website we called
audionet and then i'd go to any online
forum aol prodigy compuserve uunet
whatever it was or you use use usenet
and i like if you're interested in
dallas sports at all because we hadn't
gotten to indiana yet if you're
interested in dallas sports go to this
website audionet and back then you had a
dial-up modem you had to download the
software called tcpip
and you had to have software from your
internet provider which meant that so
few people knew how to use it we had no
idea if it would work or not
but all of a sudden audionet went from
10 people a day to 100 people to a
thousand people a day and as we added
radio stations they're getting calls
from all over the world from people who
are listening to their shows on demand
not even lined and then we worked with a
company that put together live software
company called zing
and we made it live and then everything
changed and that's really when streaming
was born
and we just grew that and then in 1998
we got into video changed the name to
broadcast.com
went public and it was the biggest ipo
in the history of the stock market at
the time um and then we sold it to yahoo
wherever you're at in life right now at
this very moment
i believe everyone has a knowing inside
of them i don't think it matters if they
have a faith or no faith i don't think
about any of that i think everyone
universally has a knowing or a truth
inside
and i think most people never learn how
to get still and hear it and most people
if they do get still and hear it they're
going to know right now live while
they're listening to you and me
are they in the right
job they're supposed to be in
or
is there are they are they playing it
small
are they in the right relationship
or are they in it and dimming their own
light because of fear that maybe they'll
be alone we all have a knowing right
and you know what i'll say about the
idea of um giving up leveling up all of
that
i think it's so important that
um you know in that moment where i had
the and again let me just say there's so
much i did wrong and i share all that
stuff too one of the things i did right
was when i had this this gut feeling as
i'm sitting there with this skin problem
this gut feeling oh you're supposed to
figure out how to how to create a beauty
company when i look back at this journey
of three years of constant rejection
down to under a thousand dollars in a
bank account
literally getting knocked down over and
over from all of these beauty retailers
that i put on a pedestal and i couldn't
understand why they were telling me i
wasn't the right fit for them
every time i would check in with my gut
right and maybe so many people out there
can relate to this because you you feel
like you're doing something you're
supposed to be doing but like for me
there was no proof around me that my
idea was right there was no traction in
my business there was nobody saying yeah
that's a great idea let me buy your
product and then i'm going to the beauty
retailers and they didn't believe in the
brand and everything around me was
saying you're wrong
and the easiest thing in life is to
confuse that
with the truth and uh my question to you
is if you suddenly found yourself to be
uh say a sophomore in college at harvard
what do you think you would study and
how do you think you'd spend your time
engaging in activities
well the thing that you're likely to be
world class at
is whatever you obsessed over from say
age 12 to 18.
you know in my case it was writing
software
uh where i would think i was good and
then i would meet somebody who would
tell me i wasn't and i would look at
their code and i went through four sort
of comeuppances of oh that's what a
really good programmer looks like and
part of the reason i worship digital
equipment was eventually it was a couple
of their very best programmers who came
and shared with me how they thought
about how they did thing and i had
studied their code and uh
and that and
there were several people who were so
key to my doing that so today
i would go into
you know software which today that means
going into artificial intelligence
uh you know computers still can't read
they
they cannot take a book of information
and say pass an ap test on that book and
that's a solvable problem but it's a
knowledge representation problem
and
you know i've always wanted to solve
that problem uh i'm jealous that maybe
one of you gets
to work on that i'm you know unlikely to
go back and be
hands on in that in that way but it's
the juiciest problem ever i've thought
about it for a long time uh so i would
go into ai yeah if you want to have
impact uh
usually delegation's important um
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started i wrote most the code
and everybody else's code i read and
kind of rewrote uh
and
that got us up to 10 people and then i
had to say to myself okay we're going to
ship code that i didn't edit
and that was hard for me uh but you know
i kind of got over that then i still
said okay i'm gonna interview everyone
and i'm gonna at least look at samples
of their code well that got us up to
about 40 people
and that was at a point where
i had sold way more software than we
could write uh because everybody was so
impressed
and i thought well i need to keep enough
collect enough money
to you know keep hiring all these people
but uh the demand was so high that you
know we were actually falling behind
that's when i hired steve
and steve figured out a
uh how to control what promises i made
to people uh and b how to hire lots of
people and good really good people and
create organizations and teams so i
delegated to steve that and he was
constantly saying to me okay we're going
to hire programmers that you've never
met and i'd say no or not and then
he would show me numerically that the
constraint wasn't going to work uh you
know so uh then i said okay then i would
you know
know all the managers of the people and
so over time
uh and of course
you know i could say the quality per
person was falling monotonically
according to me
but you know large problems
uh if you want to you know write the
most popular
office productivity software that one
person absolutely can't do that you can
write pretty code so everyone has to
decide what scale of organization they
want to work in eventually
you know my role was very much as a
leader and a reviewer of managers but
the top people and i hired some super
experienced people
uh i would make sure they were pursuing
a common vision and they were well
coordinated but in terms of a lot of
management stuff
they were way better
than i was now i had to have the
framework to know what mix of skills
that we needed and you know when they
were working well enough together but a
lot of uh
you know my value-added was picking
say to do graphics user interface or to
do an integrated office uh type thing or
to go global and not use agents to have
microsoft be present all over the world
and so yeah picking what you're good at
and how you find the other people uh to
fill in those things that's super
important and most founders don't aren't
able to scale that up and kind of give
up
the hands-on things that they used to
get a lot of uh pleasure and comfort
from so anyway we we got this company
just about ready to launch
and uh we're looking at it looking at
this little tiny fulfillment center we
were here by then in this building we
had a basement fulfillment center to
call it a fulfillment center was very
grand there's a lot of puffery it was
400 square feet
which is about the size of a one car
garage and we launched this
business and we're looking at it and we
didn't know if anybody would order from
us we really didn't and in fact one of
the uh software engineers
looked at this little space and he said
i can't figure out whether this is
incredibly optimistic or hopelessly
pathetic
um and indeed we didn't know we had no
idea whether anybody would want to buy
things in this way the business plan
called for uh generating sales very
slowly as customers changed their
attitudes the original business plan
which i thought was very optimistic at
the time called for amazon.com to
generate
70 million dollars in sales in the year
2001.
we actually generated an excess of 3
billion dollars in sales in the year
2001 and we knew by the way that we were
really on to something in those first 30
days in the first 30 days
we got
orders from all 50 states and 45
different countries with not a dollar of
advertising just all word of mouth the
first year we didn't spend anything on
advertising all of it was word of mouth
and that really forged the company as a
that we were going to focus on customer
experience because we saw the power of
word of mouth so so very very clearly in
those early days there's something great
about
word of mouth online by the way and
feedback from customers which is that
email turns off the politeness gene in
the human being it's wonderful so people
actually tell you what they really think
uh usually in all caps
and uh
so
we get lots of info and feedback from
our customers and we try to try to use
it well there's a friend of mine who's
got a great saying about creating a
company
which is
creating trying to build a company and
have it succeed is like eating glass and
staring into the abyss
so i mean what tends to happen is it's
sort of quite exciting for the first
several months of starting a company and
then then reality sets in things don't
go as well as planned customers aren't
signing up the technology or the product
isn't working as well as you thought
and
i think that can sometimes be compounded
by a recession
and
it can be
very very painful for several years um
so i think um
frankly starting a company
i would advise people to have a high
pain tolerance one of the first times
that i read that i demoed
recommendations live
with a live website i
was speaking to a group of wall street
analysts
and
and
my number one recommendation
number one personal recommendation was
the dvd called slave girls beyond
infinity
and
which was this is much less embarrassing
and you never know what you're going to
get i never know exactly what i'm going
to get because it is live and it does
change you know from minute to minute
but i'm glad to see that today i've
gotten you know apollo
and then i can see of course
why was i recommended this
because i bought cosmos and angle of
attack and another book called apollo
so
but slave girls beyond infinity
i'll just show you was
was a little embarrassing
um
what happened to that laser pointer
thing oh here it is
do not look directly into me okay
um
there it is slave girls from beyond
infinity
let's go over here
uh this is pretty interesting um
it's uh so you can buy this dvd with a
salt of the killer bimbos
buy together
it's only 1996.
all of that product clustering is done
automatically of course it the um
you come down and you'll notice that you
know customers who bought slave girls
also bought sorority babes in the slime
ball bolo rama
and my personal favorite cannibal women
in the avocado jungle of death
and there's this interesting thing here
we um we even know when things are part
of a series so we say and also they
bought dvds from the barbarian queen
series so we can click through quick
click through and look at the barbarian
queen and
um
there's a customer review here
uh it says for layna clarkson fans only
this is barbarian queen two this is not
even barbarian queen it's
an incredibly bad film whose only
redeeming feature is laina clarkson in
and out of some skimpy outfits she's
completely gorgeous but even she can't
save a disaster of a film yeah we faced
a lot of challenges but i'm sure alibaba
is going to face more challenges
we worry every day
when i was young when company was young
we thought well
what if when alibaba become that big
my life would be easier
then now the companies that the bigger
the company the more problems i have
so
why you are still small company enjoy it
you will never experience the happiness
of operating a small company
any life we're going to be too big you
have so much headaches
so many things happening
and people say jack
you know there are a lot of books about
you but there's none of the books i
write myself if there's one book i want
to write in the future it's called
alibaba 1001 mistakes
we made so many mistakes
we had so many troubles
believing or not
china
built up e-commerce company
build up a internet-related company
no internet connection at that time
no v no no credit cards
no delivery system
it's so we make we meet problems all the
time
it's not easy
but we tell ourselves
we will be successful until we make 10
000 mistakes
we'll be successful
if we survive in any crisis
so when crisis came we know it's a
challenge
everybody
start to be united we solve the
challenge then we complete each other
before
we solve the problem of the crisis
we should not complain
though
i have a problem in in
i have a problem in financing i have a
problem in technology i have a problem
everywhere tell me so that's why i i
become a mentor in entrepreneurs uh
program in china
people a lot of entrepreneurs have
crashing when i listen to their
questions oh my god i have this problem
too so
i would say
we have gone through almond almost nine
more than 90 percent
of the problems that any entrepreneur 90
of the problems that any entrepreneurs
have met this is what we feel proud
at the end of the day i'm gonna tell my
kids my grandchildren
it's not the thing we feel proud we we
made alibaba
it's so many mistakes
that we overcome
so many challenges we experienced that
make me feel proud life is about
experience so when you become
entrepreneur
don't worry about the competitors
don't worry about the mistakes
don't worry about the challenges
go through it that's the great fun part
of your business of your experience and
then
you got a courage you got a wisdom you
got a team follow you do you remember
how much your first server cost you said
oh yeah eighty-five dollars eighty-five
dollars yeah and i remember that because
um that was the gating factor for us
launching new schools i i mean we had
this philosophy from the very beginning
that we didn't want to be this project
it wasn't even a company at the very
beginning but we didn't want to be
burning a lot of money right we weren't
planning on raising a lot of money we
didn't want to be one of these things
that raised a bunch of money and you
know was losing a bunch of money and
then decided that we'd somehow pull it
through at the end and um so you know so
85 for the first server put ads on the
site and the the ads at the beginning
were uh we just were running some kind
of ad network and remember what the
first ad was
um
no i don't um
i don't know how did you get ads um
this was eduardo's job
was i mean with your ad sales yeah he
basically like he was responsible for
making sure that we had enough money to
keep things running in the beginning and
um
you know but basically i mean so it was
the server was 85 and you know dustin
and i basically worked on kind of
efficiency and making sure that we can
fit more schools onto each server
and um and eduardo worked on selling
more ads or making a deal so that we can
get an ad network so that way we can we
can make more money but then whenever we
had more money we rented another 85 a
month server and we kind of went from
there and um i don't know just it's just
an interesting way of seeing never spent
money you didn't have in the beginning
not in the beginning no and then i mean
even that was the constraint on your
growth rate how many new 85 dollars is
you could get yeah and i mean it was
actually good because i i mean you know
sometimes it's really nice to have the
time to
get your product to be awesome and deal
with scaling problems and one of the
things that was interesting was um
you know at the time i don't know how
many people remember this but i mean
friendster was the service that had
massive scaling problems yeah you know
the idea was they were they grew quickly
and it was really hard for them to scale
and um you know the fact that we could
kind of go college by college and and
kind of optimize the service and make it
more efficient and offer new features
but make sure that they worked um i
think was really key i mean we're you're
talking about people who've never built
a company before we never built any
large scale software
or anything so having that period where
we could just bake it
and you know people these days like to
talk about how these services grow super
quickly and facebook did grow quickly
but i think it took a year for us to get
a million users and we thought that that
was incredibly fast but um and and i
think it is but
it wasn't as quick as a lot of things
grow today and i think actually having
that time to bake it was really valuable
process of me cutting the feet out of my
pantyhose while trying to get the
prototype made before i launched it was
two years so there was a year solid of
me driving in north carolina on the
weekends and at night or taking time off
from work to go and work on the
prototype get it made i learned so many
things that i didn't know as a consumer
it had never dawned on me you know that
men were making all of our undergarments
so i learned very quickly that the
industry had been taking an average
waistband size between a small
and an extra large and putting the same
waistband on every pair
exactly that's what i said i said you
know
that's not working
we're really uncomfortable and they were
doing it to cut cost and production so i
immediately changed that in a spanx
waistband a size small gets a small
medium gets a medium and so on makes
perfect sense right
i also realized that they had been
putting a tiny rubber cord inside the
waistbands that had been there forever
well we had made so many advancements in
yarns that they no longer needed the
rubber cord but no one had stopped to
say do we still need to put this so i
immediately took the rubber cord out of
it and another thing i learned was the
way that they were doing sizing was just
so blew me away they would figure out a
size by putting them on plastic forms
and they would all put it on a plastic
form they had different size forms and
they would stand back with their
clipboards and go
yep that's a size medium
and i'd lean in and i go
ask her how she feels
so at spanx we put our product on women
my mother my grandmother who's 90
my sister-in-law cassie i mean all of my
friends the girls at spanx we're testing
it on real women and we want to test it
more than two seconds to say yep that
looks like a medium we we have people
wear it for a week wash it tell us if it
rolled did it move did it stay in place
how did you feel very concerned with
spanx garments and how they made you
feel when you get a 1 000 on your s.a.t
i probably got like a 980. i've
convinced myself that i broke a thousand
creativity becomes a survival skill it's
a necessity to get into the door to
interview to sell everything for me
revolved around creativity so one day at
the recording studio i walk in and
there's a cassette sitting on the music
board and it's the cassette that changed
my life
the cassette was by an artist a rat
pioneer named dana dane dana was a
brooklyn-born artist his first album was
one of my favorite albums and this was
an advanced copy in the late 80s that
nobody
or nobody had
sitting there i wanted to listen to it
so i asked the engineer if i could
borrow the cassette and i would bring
the cassette back after i listen to it
he says sure
a couple of days later i'm on my way to
los angeles to visit a friend i'm
listening to it in my sony walkman if
anyone remembers those sony walkman yeah
and when i'm on the plane i read that
the owner of delicious finals favorite
artist this is a big label tone lok and
young his favorite artist is dana dane
so when i land in california i cold
called delicious vinyl i get all the way
up to the assistant of this guy she has
no idea what i'm talking about i'm
talking very fast like a new yorker i
have dana's tape i know mike's a fan of
daina
she puts me on hold
she comes back two minutes later and she
says dana
if you can be here at two o'clock mike
russ would love to meet you
dana will be there at two o'clock
two o'clock comes the dana's a
brooklyn-born guy like i said
african-american goldtooth
not me
i pushed the
now a good friend of mine though
push the button they said i said hey i'm
dana here from micros oh
mike is expecting you dana come right in
i walk in they escort me into the office
loc's record young's record he's got
this funky candle going they sit me down
i'm sitting there i'm waiting no idea
what's going to happen in walks
mike ross
and says to me not as politely who in
the world are you
there's a famous quote by harry truman
if you can't convince them
confuse them
it works so far
so i start saying oh i work at the same
studio as dana i know you're a fan of
dana he must be late he has an advanced
tape
can i put in my cassette that i did at
the in the studio you have a cassette
what do you do
i rap
huh put it in
put in my cassette and he says the four
words that every artist struggling
artist wants to hear
who's your lawyer
i don't have a lawyer i have a dad so i
give him my dad's number my dad owns a
plumbing
my dad owns a plumbing supply house in
mineola
i call my father when we leave i said
dad i think i just got a record deal if
someone calls you
we got our foot in the door we're gonna
figure the rest out later get all the
documents
that started a journey of getting my
foot in the door
and figuring it out later a key thing in
creativity starting the process trusting
the process and letting it evolve
because if you don't get your foot in
the door if you don't start
nothing happens i did it with a company
called marquee jet we sold it to warren
buffett i did it with our company's eco
coconut water we sold it to coca-cola on
an individual level i think it is always
uh it's always really good if if there's
something that you're incredibly
passionate about and um and just sort of
are fine to be intrinsically interesting
and and that that people pursue that um
and so the you know one of the
one of the the resolutions i came up
with a number of years ago was to always
value substance over status substance
over prestige um
and you know if i sort of was giving my
younger self advice on what to what to
do or how to how to think about um
your when's one's life i you know i
probably i think i you know um
i probably would still go to stanford um
you know i i might still go to law
school um but i'd ask i'd ask sort of
i'd ask a lot more questions why why i
was doing these things and i think
i think if i was honest about it
too much of it was driven by
um by prestige and status and not quite
enough about um really the substance of
uh of trying to learn things and you
know i had sort of this i sort of think
of it as this sort of crazy rolling
quarter life crisis and sort of
culminated in this uh in this you know
big new york law firm where you know
from the outside everybody wanted to get
in from the inside everybody wanted to
get out um you know um after i lasted
seven months and three days and after uh
um and uh when i when i when i left one
of the people down the hall said you
know it's so reassuring to see you leave
peter i had no idea it was possible to
escape from alcatraz which which again
uh and you know and again i and all you
had to do was go through the front door
but our identity um people's identities
get so wrapped up in um the things they
compete for that it was inconceivable
for people to actually do that and and
then the question was you know well how
had i ended up there why had i not
thought about that more and i think it
was um that i had taken too many of
these shortcuts of valuing sort of what
was prestigious what was conventional
over what i uh what i really wanted to
do so i think i think always substance
over status what do you think it'll take
for you to get over insecurity moving
forward
i'm not trying to you're not trying i'm
not trying to
i thought you said if you could get rid
of it you'd be able to do bigger the
unbelievable
but but it's not it's not it's not a
target i have
letting go of insecurity no i think it's
just a human condition i think it's part
of the game i think it's part of being a
human being any more than i want to get
rid of my arms you know or my legs or my
arms and my legs my body my body is a
limitation
yeah you know so um how do you manage it
better then like for people that are
saying i you know i want a 10x but i
always have insecurity and fear that i'm
going to fail and people are going to
show up and yeah the deal's going to i'm
going to go broke
how do you personally
get a conversation to yourself to the
insecurity and fear yeah it's not stop
it's come
you know for me for me fear fear the
things i i'm scared of i'm like
come on you know they it's calling me
says hey come play over here
it's an indicator it's a good indicator
not a bad indicator lean into it lean
into it come play with me okay so i
either have fear because it's really
dangerous and stupid
or like physically dangerous yeah let me
get to the edge of this thing i'm gonna
get on the other side of that thing i'm
probably gonna be scared yeah now why
why am i gonna be scared though
like because i don't know what it feels
like to fall
you know this many floors and hit yeah
maybe it does maybe there's no big deal
about maybe dying is not even a big deal
right but i don't have the exp i don't
consciously have the experience
so
you know i used to be like
i can't buy a seventy eight thousand
dollar house i was terrified the first
house i bought
i don't know what i'm doing because
you're gonna have experience i don't
have the experience man yeah this this
is the problem and you're not gonna have
the experience if you don't move through
the fear
and
a lot of people do it once and then they
don't do it again you got like
it's not going away yeah it's just gonna
you're gonna get used to
you're gonna get used to the ski boots
you know the first time you put them on
man they're freaking banging your shins
like i can't man
but you just
we're into them we also are big
believers in in united way and and what
goes on there and that's more at a
business level we sort of think every
business ought to do that it's a basic
thing because social services
we think have a
deserve particular priority in terms of
drawing employees in to
to help help the community and there's
ways to take those fundraising things
within a company and have contests and
comparisons and great stories get the
word out make it fun make it easy you
know it's just a piece of email the
easiest thing to do is click and say you
want to give your fair share and then we
send you no more email uh so we've
made it the easiest thing to do is is uh
is
participate in terms of individuals it's
quite different
you know you can take and give to groups
like united way who are really thinking
about everything in the community or you
can find things and most people mix this
you can find things that you're
particularly interested in that you know
about that a relative benefited from or
that you want to go and volunteer
in
uh you know microsoft does the thing now
for every hour that somebody volunteers
we actually uh make a grant to that
organization because that says that
there they care about it and they think
it's it's doing very good work
now for individuals at some levels
probably most you're giving is going to
be
in the community where you know what's
going on
i'm a big believer that that the some of
the greatest inequities are on a global
basis
and so uh one of the things our
foundation tries to get out is the names
of a number of organizations like save
the children or global fund or vaccine
fund that we know
are taking dollars in a very efficient
way and saving lives and improving
conditions and you know i would hope
that as people
are able to be fairly generous that this
international component that it be part
of of what they're doing in the
beginning nobody wanted a tesla i can
tell you that
the the the when we made the original
sort of roadster sports car
uh people like why would i want an
electric car that's
my gasoline
car works fine
i'm like no electric car is better i
should try it
and it was you know hard to get people
to
do a test drive first one nobody knew
who we were and then we heard this
company
and like yeah we're named after nikola
tesla you know that guy nope
um
so
for sure we were doing push in the
beginning because people said there was
no one telling us that they wanted an
electric car so it was not it was not
out of like
you know it was like lots of people
coming up to me saying yeah i really
want an electric car
i heard that zero times um
some people like it's like man we're
gonna make an electric car and show that
these things can be good um and then
people want them
um
you know it's like it goes like henry
ford said that like the you know
we're talking about the model t it's
like if you ask the public what they
wanted they'd say a faster horse
so if you did like a big survey and say
well hey public
before automobiles
what would you like it's like well i'd
like my horse to go three miles an hour
faster and eat less food and
uh
you know be stronger and
live longer and that kind of thing
there will be basically a bunch of
incremental improvements on horse um
because people when you say like what
about an automobile that car that drives
itself like what are you talking about
that's not that sounds crazy
um
but when you actually make an automobile
and give it to people and say okay
now this is a horse where you can keep
it in the barn and if you leave for a
month it's still alive
yeah
so carry more more weight than a horse
and go further and that kind of thing so
anyway
it's like when when it's a radically new
product people don't know that they want
it because it's just not in their
in their scope i think when they first
started making tvs
they did a nationwide survey
i think this might have been like
46 or 48. it's like famous nationwide
survey will you ever buy a tv
now i was like 96 percent of respondents
said no
someone some crazy number
like basically everyone's like would you
buy a tv and maybe they put a price in
there or something i don't know but
it was famously
almost everyone said they would not buy
tv but they didn't know what they're
talking about
so the big game changing stuff at the
beginning is a company push kind of a
thing most of the time but then
changes to the product over time can be
a lot more customer pull kind of a focus
yeah change changes to the product over
time can be
incremental changes
um
then the customers can certainly tell
you it's good to get customer feedback
to say how can we improve the product um
and once they're using it they can say
okay i like this thing about it i don't
like this other thing and then we can
improve the product over time customer
feedback after they they have
the fundamental thing
is great if we've given the world a
voice look at what's happened in the
last year you've had elections in the
last years elections manipulated hate
speech that's gone viral and turned
offline
it certainly seems like this mission
has been accomplished in many ways and
and there's a whole new set of problems
that perhaps you guys didn't foresee um
and now we're in a very complicated
place where there's not an easy solution
yeah there's these are complex issues
that you can't fix you manage them on an
ongoing basis
but
look
do you think that the world is better
with everyone having a voice and having
the ability to express their opinion
and being able to connect to who they
want i don't think we're going back to a
world where there were just a handful of
gatekeepers who got to control what
ideas get expressed
and even if we could well i'm trying to
make it so we're not i mean that's why
um making it so that we're building
these independent governance mechanisms
and things like that are really
important and that's that's work that i
that i really care about
um
but i think that the world will keep on
moving in this direction um people will
more people will keep on getting a voice
uh i think that that's good and and and
i think there are certainly going to be
issues that we need to work through over
time but i think that while we are doing
that we can't lose sight of all of the
really positive things that are that are
happening here as well
not just in terms of communities and
people being able to to connect with
with groups that are really meaningful
to them whether it's around a disease or
or a community around veterans that they
wouldn't be able to connect to otherwise
but even if you just think about the
economic impact
of what we're doing
you know we serve 80 million small
businesses around the world about half
of them have told us that they're hiring
people because of using our tools and
that without facebook and the tools that
we that we provide um that they that
their business would be significantly
smaller and they wouldn't be hiring as
many people as they are
so you know a study came out the us
economy added about four and a half
million jobs over the last year
if you just look at like what people are
telling us the small businesses who use
our tools
we've directly been able to contribute
to creating many more jobs than that
across the world so i think that
this is the power of giving people a
voice giving small businesses giving
communities giving everyone everywhere
the ability to connect with the people
who who they care about and get their
opinion across and giving everyday
people the power that previously only
big companies would have had so that's
it the world is going to go more in that
direction and i think by and large
that's a good thing so i'm really proud
of the work that we're doing on this and
we there are big issues and i'm not
trying to to say that there aren't that
we need to work through but i i do think
that sometimes you can you can get the
flavor
from a lot of this from from some of the
coverage that um
that's all there is and um and i don't
think that that's right either we need
to make sure that we address these
these questions um these are really big
and important things for the future of
our society and the future of the
internet um but we also need to keep
pushing in the direction of empowering
more people when god created this planet
he created of several species
now if you're an atheist it's okay call
it the force let me just say god for now
so i don't have to say god the forest
god the forest let's just say god right
now god creates a planet earth and first
of all he creates which a lot of people
in different organizations want a
perfect social economic world where
everything is free don't worry about a
thing you're taken care of there's no
extra imagination necessary
it's all gonna be given to you so he
creates the oyster he says oyster i'm
giving you a free house to live in i'm
calling it a shell i'm gonna put at the
bottom of the ocean
to protect you from your enemies you
have food clothing all the food you want
protection
everything you want the perfectly taken
care of while you're in your measly
little life as an oyster but you're not
going to go anywhere
you stay there at the bottom of the
ocean but you totally got your free food
free clothing free everything you want
then god created something called the
eagle eagle whole different species
eagle
you want a house you go out and build it
take the top of a mountain take the top
of a tree go out and build your own
house you want some food to eat no
problem go out there and find it eagle
and the eagle flies through miles in the
winter time of rain sleet snow and wind
just to feed its young
did you know the eagle
fails 95
of the time a total failure it's so big
and cumbersome that when it comes upon
its prey
they're wild they shoot off in a
different direction and it misses
five percent of the time it succeeds
and what does succeed to do it succeeded
to be the strongest bird in the sky
the only one that we know of anywhere in
the world that could fly into the
thermals of a hurricane and ride them to
have fun
now the eagle unlike the oyster can go
anywhere it wants anywhere it wants yeah
gambles it does this on its own but it
goes wherever it wants now that eagle
and not the oyster is the emblem of
america
and also on the flag of many many
countries as a general matters of one
piece of specific finance
financial advice
i would say you know avoid credit cards
just forget about them
uh we're in various businesses that
issue credit cards the american public
loves credit cards but if you start
revolving debt on credit cards you're
going to be paying
18 or 20 percent and
you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at 18 or 20
percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at 18 or 20 over time you know if
you can find anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation
that's always behind in life
uh you know i was lucky i'd saved about
ten thousand dollars by the time i got
out of school that ten thousand dollars
was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the expenses roll
in but but those were my tools to work
with but it was only because i was ahead
of the game if you're behind the game by
ten thousand dollars at some point and
paying eighteen or twenty percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it so the trick
i've got a partner that says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there you know and
uh
and that's true in financial matters as
well you want to figure out where you
don't want to be
ahead of time and avoid that and i get
about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems
and there are two reasons why they have
terrible problems one is
a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in
they run up bills they can't pay and and
really only society can solve that one
uh uh in terms of protecting people
against that that's just plain bad luck
but
the other one is from people who run up
credit card debt and uh they're facing
bankruptcy they've been through
bankruptcy once before
and they owe a whole bunch of money and
they can't they can't even pay the
interest let alone pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable catastrophic illness is not
but but
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better
it's way easier to stay out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and
i will guarantee if you run a big credit
card that you will be in trouble
uh probably the rest of your life in
terms of uh your financial situation on
the other hand if you get ahead of the
game
uh
even it's on a very modest scale
so that money is coming in from
investing
and you're you're you people owe you
money or equities owe you ownership uh
you'll be way out of the game compared
to paying it uh
being always being paying
your creditors every month so my advice
to you is
if you can't pay for it don't buy it the
future has no experts
right
we
entrepreneurs someday we are the experts
right so this is what i think
and
when you
when entrepreneurs get used to
failure
today say alibaba you succeed
well
our company won't last 102 years
why 102 years because every target every
goal we give to our team should be very
accurate
we were born in 1999 last century we had
one year we want to spend 100 years and
plus one year one or two across three
centuries
so very accurate we never see we are
successful because we are only 19 years
old there's 83 years to go
so we will never see we're successful we
just survived 19 years we are lucky
but
in the past 19 years we have made
thousands of mistakes as an entrepreneur
don't learn from other people how they
succeed
learn from how these people feel
because
a lot of mba schools they teach you
success
successful case studies when you read
too many successful you think you can be
successful no
[Applause]
there are a lot of things that you don't
know
because you know some
business school came to alibaba write
case studies
they say i know this is alibaba and i
said no this is not alibaba they wanted
me to sign after one week
study they say this is case study
alibaba ace no this is not me they say
jack you don't know you
and that's all right i sighed
and
next to five years every year there is a
case study in qinghua university i was
invited sitting at the back listening to
the mba schools talk learning about our
case study and they always put a
competitor
competitor in alibaba who will succeed
for five years all they always agree
alibaba will die the competitor will win
but five years all the competitors died
so how can you learn from the case study
like that
learn from the mistakes
because the mistake most of the
companies i i talked to entrepreneurs
most of the mistakes they made are the
same
most of the success reasons you don't
know the different reasons
so when you learn from the mistakes not
because you want to avoid the mistakes
because when you see the mistakes when
you have this kind of problems you know
how to face it
an entrepreneur have a strong heart
towards the difficulties mistakes the
troubles the failures but should it be a
warm and soft heart to your colleagues
and to the customers we haven't had any
existential crisis knock on wood i find
i don't want to jinx anything
but we've had a lot of uh
kind of
dramatic events i remember
early on
we only had 125 employees
when barnes and noble who the big united
states bookseller um opened their online
website to compete against us barnes
noble.com we'd had about a two year
window we opened in 95
they opened in 97
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were about how we were
about to be destroyed by this much
larger company we had 125 employees
and
60 million dollars a year in annual
sales 60 million with an m
and that
and barnes noble at the time had 30 000
employees
and about 3 billion dollars in sales
so they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were um very negative about
amazon and the the one that's most
minimal or memorable was just
amazon.toast
and um
and so i call it all hands meeting which
was not hard to do with just 125 people
and we got in a room and because it was
so um scary for all of us
this idea that now we finally had a big
competitor that literally
everybody's parents were calling and
saying you know are you okay
it's usually the moms um
calling and asking their children are
you gonna be okay so and i said look you
know it it's okay to be afraid um but
don't be afraid of our competitors
because they're never going to send us
any money be afraid of our customers and
if we just stay focused on them in in in
in instead of
obsessing over this big competitor that
we just got
that we'll be fine um and i really do
believe that i think that if you stay
focused then the more
uh
drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is
the the what your response to it should
be to double down on the customer
satisfying them not just satisfying them
delighting them when i was a kid glenn i
was like
i knew i was going to do something great
and had
zero reason to believe that
right
like it was a total fantasy
or maybe not
i think everybody has that i would
imagine that every kid
um
has this idea that they're they're
they're meant for greatness
i know i did i always thought i was
gonna be something great i remember my
twin brother uh he he would he'd be in
the mirror man he's like eight years old
we're eight years old he's singing in
here like he's a rock star right i had
to listen to that all the time
and and then i started thinking man man
if he's gonna be a rock star
what he's gonna go on and be a big rock
star
and and and i can't you know
because i that that that wasn't my deal
i said what am i going to be
and then i thought i'm going to be a
baseball player
i actually believed i was going to be a
baseball player right dude i wasn't fast
enough i wasn't strong enough i didn't
have the arm i mean i had no talent
i didn't have the work ethic you know i
didn't have somebody pushing me so
i just always underestimated what i
could do i think everybody does that
that's why this 10x thing that's why i
keep telling people man you're you're
thinking too small when i talk to people
about real estate don't do two units
gotta start somewhere no you don't have
to start with two units
you could actually start with 32
right
and and by the way it's going to be a
lot easier to make money on 32 than it
is to
sure
if if you could just believe that you
can
you know and right now is a time where
people are going to have to start
believing they can do something else
because we're going to move into a
period of time now
where there's going to be massive
transition enforced transition on
everyone one part that i'm always um
very focused on is sort of the structure
of these companies and how how well are
people aligned and so you can um
and uh making sure that people are you
know aligned properly not just that they
say i think this is sort of a very a
very legal kind of a framework to think
about what are people's incentives you
know are they going to be aligned or not
and i think you want to both have formal
alignment where you set the structure
right and you want to have
informal alignment where the people
would naturally try to work together
well in one one way or another
and i think that somehow tends to get
obscured in all these other ways um you
know there's always a there's always a
uh there's always a
prehistory question i like to ask
founders of of companies which is um
how did you uh how did you um
meet what's the prehistory of the
company before you got started
i find that to be really instructive a
set of questions to ask a bad answer is
something like you know we met a week
ago at a social networking function at a
business networking function we decided
to start a company because we both
wanted to be entrepreneurs
um you know that's like saying i married
the first person i met at the slot
machines in las vegas and you might hit
the jackpot but it's probably a really
bad idea
and a much better answer is you know
we've been talking about this for a long
time you know maybe
one of us is more on the tech side the
other one's more on the business side we
have these sort of complementary skills
and and so i think this question of
alignment and structure is um is
incredibly important sometimes it's like
god has other plans it's like something
hits you and you don't even know and
well frankly the things going through my
mind were what's you know what's what's
going on what's wrong with me uh
i would try i would spend my makeup
trying to cover it up because rosacea's
bright red and you get these um patches
on your skin and they're textured like
sandpaper like a rush right almost yes
and it's very textured and so um no i
mean i think anytime you know something
happens to us whether it's a physical
thing a physical change an emotional
situation um something with our health
right anytime we have something like
that you know the the
it's hard
to go through the the beginning of it
because i struggled a little bit
honestly i had thoughts like okay
am i pretty anymore like just those
things like i'm embarrassed i never even
said that out loud by the way but like
that's the truth i just started doubting
myself i started um
doubting okay is this gonna affect my
career you know but
in in the midst of the the start of kind
of that that i guess struggle of going
okay
my physical appearance is changing let
me wrap my head around this um uh is
when i started really looking into
makeup and and trying everything out
there spending my tiny paycheck on on uh
every product i could get my hands on
from the most expensive to least
expensive and and there's that famous
saying like you know sometimes we make
our mess our message and that's sort of
what happened it was this
entrepreneurial moment where
i realized there's nothing out there
that works for me right nothing that
will solve my problem and there must be
so many other people that have just
given up on makeup because it doesn't
work for them and it's like okay
nothing worked i went to dallas after um
college because a bunch of my buddies
were down there and i got a job working
as a bartender at night and was looking
for a job during the day and got a job
working for a retail software company
and this was in the early days of pcs
and was doing okay there and then about
nine months in i made um let me had i
was living six guys in a three bedroom
apartment and i was sleeping on the
floor it was the rattiest nastiest
[ __ ] you've ever seen in your life
i mean and i literally didn't have a
closet didn't have a drawer all my [ __ ]
was in a pile on the floor i had my one
towel that i stole from motel 6 that had
a hole in it that was mine um
and so i was trying to grind it out and
learn tech which i really realized that
i loved and i made the one day i called
up my boss a guy named michael humecki
h-u-m-e-c-k-i and i said michael i've
got this deal i'm going to close now
it's 1500 commission to me which meant i
can move out of the shuttle
and and so i said
one of my responsibilities was to open
up the retail store you know make sure
the door was open the floors were clean
and all that kind of stuff i said look
i've got this big deal i want to close
it and he said no you need to be at the
store i'm like i got someone to watch
goes no you need to be at the store so i
made the executive decision that if i
went and picked up a 15 000 check for
this company um your business software
he would see the light and all would be
good and i'd have my 1500 dollar
commission
fired my ass um seriously michael
humecki and um
one time one time literally after
broadcast.com went public he sent me a
letter asking if i would invest in his
company
you should bring him on shark tank
anyway so that was the only time i've
talked to michael humecki and so
and so he fired me and so there i was
still in the [ __ ] with my one motel
six towel um and no bedrooms and so it
was then that we started micro solutions
and i had no money and so i went to this
company called architectural lighting
and i said look i got nothing but i know
you were trying you want this time in
billing software if you front me the 500
i'm going to start this company and i
promise you that i'll make it work and
if i can't make it work i'll walk your
dog i'll wash you know your car i'll do
whatever to make it up to you just trust
me and give me the shot they did i took
that 500 bought the spent 250 on the
software
got that to work really fast and then
asked for referrals and built this
company that then went on to become one
of the first companies that did local
area network this was the early 80s and
then went wide area networks and as you
said we sold it to compuserve and along
the way i kept on reinvesting and
one day i went to the atm
and i had all zeros you know which which
was not fun but like you said we we
ended up building it we had 36 million
dollar revenue run rate and sold it to
compuserve which was part of h r block
and you know all was in alignment again
and it wasn't like i started it thinking
okay if i fail i don't care it was
purely out of necessity i didn't know
what else to do i always
was dancing to my own drum my parents
gave me a really long leash which was a
great gift for me growing up they let me
do whatever i wanted to do
within reason yeah and i always you know
all of us we always come against this
wall of fear you know this crazy wall of
fear and you can either go to the wall
and turn around you can go through the
wall yes and i was i always every time i
went around turned around and went back
home because i was too scared i had
crazy resentment
or crazy guilt that i wasn't able to do
it regret not resentment yeah regret
yeah and every time i went through the
wall
and got to the other side it was so
addicting and i was so proud of myself
so uh let me just give you a quick
example when i was growing up i grew up
in new york city uh on long island in
the 80s when break dancing and rap and
all this stuff was happening yep and i
was really into breakdancing i don't
know i don't look like it
but you know get some cardboard out here
man we need to do something might get
some cardboard
and
i decided that like i could make more
money probably if i went to washington
dc you know because the kids in
washington dc couldn't be as good as the
kids in new york we invented this whole
genre so i got my friend myron who's my
partner my sister just got her driver's
license and i convinced her to drive us
to washington dc and the whole drive
down i was having all that self-doubt
yeah you know at a young age 14 15 years
old like what if the kids are better
what if no one shows up what if we get
booed what if you know what if we go
there and i stink yeah and so i was
almost talking myself out i was building
the wall of doubt up brick by brick in
my own head yeah and when we got there
we went to a little bank in uh
georgetown and we set up a boom box in a
parking lot of a bank and we hit play
and my friend started spinning on his
head and he passed it to me and a crowd
gathered around and ultimately after i
did my thing more people came i took my
hat and i passed it around we made about
200 i paid my sister for the gas money
and then myron and i split 82
41 each and this guy you know he's
counting up the money and he's counting
up the money and he gets all the money
and then he sprints over to me and he
gives me a bear hug and he goes jess
rich
and
what the reason why we were rich is
because on that particular trip despite
all the fear this young little kid that
was so scared
i went around that wall
and i realized i could be rewarded
and i was like i want more of that how
did you get through like tactically to a
sale in the encyclopedia world like
people don't want to hear from you so
like how do you overcome that
what a question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days
i was at it for three and a half years
and the way it worked in those days it
was commission only so the way it worked
is you went for an interview they told
you all you could possibly make of
commission only and we were in training
for three days it was a presentation
that was scripted we'd have to memorize
the whole thing well when you got in the
field you remember parts of it you knock
on doors you're not quite sure of
yourself a lot of doors are closed in
your face but what happens after a while
you start getting used to it and you see
what you can say or do
that'll make it better but when you go
back the next day with your other sales
people what you see what you do what did
i say
uh so let's say i knock on 100 door skin
into one give 10 presentations to sell
one book but then when you get better
and better at it through your
experiences and losses along the way it
sharpens you up where all of a sudden i
got to a point where if i gave three
presentations i have no less than one
order commission only but i believe that
i could do that i believe that colleges
with the best set of books because a
high school student could read it it
wasn't like a college manual you had to
read and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe that
what you're doing is good is going to
benefit somebody and you learn as you go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people don't know these things
look someone the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye because you feel
uncomfortable of course you do they're
not on the same wavelength you're on or
the same frequency so what do you do how
do you overcome that you learn these
things along the way you look them right
between the eyes or their eyebrows looks
like you're looking over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh there's all these things
and of course smile smile's the most
wonderful thing god gave us and you
don't smile when you first talk to
somebody you smile before you knock on
their door
and if your day sucks you fake it
hi how you doing so when you smile
everything changes people change
everybody works hard
and everybody has their own dreams
there is
there was a time
where i used to spend a lot of energy
wanting things
wanting things
of course it's easy for me to say oh
things don't define you because i got a
lot of things things are nice i like
them
but this is what i learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space
that you purposefully have come to earth
to claim for yourself so
around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning uh
sunday morning should have been in
church but i wouldn't
i was reading
the new york times review of the color
purple
and i thought whoa this sounds like a
really great book i got out of bed in my
pajamas put on my galoshes
and
went to the store to get the copy of the
color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore bought every
book of the color purple i took the
books to to the office and i said to
everybody y'all got to read this book oh
my god you got to read this book color
purple i needed a book club i didn't
have one
so i passed out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear
that somebody's gonna do a movie about
the color purple but i don't know
anybody in the movie business by this
time i was on am chicago i don't know
anybody i start praying to god god
please help me find a way to get into
color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as
as divine law would have it quincy jones
comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one half of a
day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson claiming that
billie jean was their lover and that's
not his song
[Applause]
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room
he was coming out of the shower
and the television in his hotel room is
on am chicago
there sits
little chubby me
with my jared curl
on am chicago
quincy jones tells ruben cannon the
casting agent i think i found sophia so
i get a call
from ruben cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song would you be
interested to come and audition and i
say i have not been praying for moon
song
[Applause]
[Music]
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well
i think you should come and and audition
so i go to audition
you know movie people they make
everything all secret steven spielberg
didn't want anybody know he was doing
color purple so on the outside of the
script it says moon song but i know all
the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus this is the color
purple
yes
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie oh that i'm
thinking prayer prayer works
prayer works
but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february
march
april may comes i haven't heard anything
so i call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon
i'm sorry sir i haven't heard anything i
expected to hear something by now and
reuben cannon
african-american man
says to me
you don't call me
i call you
and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying i can't believe that god has
played this trick on me i think
this is a trick
so i decide that this is because the fat
has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
[Applause]
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose
25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i
i i also
was trying to make peace with it
i said god i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
[Applause]
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says real
actresses have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track
at the fat farm
it starts to rain
y'all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life i start praying
running around the track
[Music]
and i keep hearing this noise and i i
can't there's nobody on the track but me
and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
[Applause]
it's my thighs
[Applause]
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
[Applause]
there's nobody on the track so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me
help me let it go help me let it go help
me let it go god help me let it go
and you ever did this prayer where you
say okay lord i'll come and let it go
then you get up and you go well i think
i still got a little bit of it
i did help me let it go
but i am not going to be able to see the
other actress
in my part i won't be able to see it
won't be able to see color purple just
can't never see it the rest of my life i
won't be able to see it
so then i started
i don't know where it came from
i surrender all
i
surrender
all
all
to thee my
blessed savior
i
surrender
all
i sang and i cried
i sang and i cried and i prayed some
more
until i could reach the point where not
only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless the other actress
i can bless her
i can say
i bless you i bless you i bless you with
this i surrender
all i
surrender all
all
to thee
my
blessed savior
i
surrender all
and i tell you
in my greatest testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
[Applause]
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me anymore
it had no control over me anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally
surrendered it to the power that was
greater than i could ever know the
instant that happened
a woman comes running out of the
cafeteria
screaming offering
is your name all free
for ten years nobody could pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's ain't named
spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
[Applause]
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
[Applause]
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound
you could lose this part
no
problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
[Applause]
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
[Applause]
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said you're
hired you're hired
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there i was just gonna be myself i
find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm quite grumpy
i mean obviously i think most people
that way you just have to develop the
ability to say no and and
do it a few times